quatre mois jour pour jour après les
attentats du 11 septembre les premiers
prisonniers afghans sont arrivés hier
soir sur une base américaine à cuba
jugé très dangereux par les états unis
ces détenus talibans ou membres du
réseau al qaïda ont commencé à être
interrogé jean-marc pitte avant même
leur arrivée les cagoules menottes et
sédatif utilisé durant le transfert
aérien de ces détenus faisait déjà
l'objet d'une polémique
c'est peut être l'une des raisons qui
ont poussé les autorités militaires
américaines à entourer leur débarquement
de la plus grande discrétion
seuls ces images très lointaine tournée
de l'extérieur de la base ont pu être
diffusées
leur statut juridique reste également
très flou les etats unis le refuge celui
de prisonnier de guerre
ils ne seront pas traités comme des
prisonniers de guerre parce qu'ils n'en
sont pas ce sont des combattants
illégaux et si j'ai bien compris
techniquement les combattants illégaux
ne bénéficie pas de la convention de
genève
mais nous avons indiqué que nous
prévoyons de les traiter pour la plupart
en accord avec les dispositions de la
convention de genève
guantanamo est une enclave américaine de
115 kilomètres carrés en territoire
cubain
les autorités de la havane revendique la
rétrocession de cette partie de leur
territoire
mais cuba n'a pas protesté contre le
transfert des prisonniers à guantanamo
le gouvernement cubain a indiqué hier
qu'il en avait été informé et qu'il
était même prêt à fournir une aide
médicale des promesses d'allègement de
l'embargo sur cuba pourrait expliquer
cette surprenante compréhension